[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen guten Abend und
willkommen das Wichtigste vom Sport an
diesem Samstag hat Rudi zerne für Sie
gerne hallo schönen guten Abend unsere
Themen Schritte aufeinander zu in kiefev
bescheinigt die eu-
kommmissionspräsidentin der Ukraine Land
sei auf gutem Weg hin zu
Beitrittsverhandlungen für die Sache der
Palästinenser mindestens 8500 Menschen
demonstrieren in Berlin auch mit
verbotenen Bannern und Parolen die
Polizei hält sich
zurück und von nun an getrennte Wege
Martina Forst Tecklenburg ist gut dre
Monate nach dem WM debakkel nicht mehr
Trainerin der deutschen
Fußballfrauen
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von derlin ist
heute in der ukrainis Hauptstadt kiefev
es geht dabei vor allem um einen
möglichen EU-Beitritt des Landes die
große Frage ist ob
Beitrittsverhandlungen eröffnet werden
sollen im Dezember entscheiden darüber
die EU Staats- und regierungschefinnen
und Chefs vorher soll Ursula vonder
derlin ihre Einschätzung abgeben über
den Besuch Dara Hassan Sade es ist von
derlein sechste Reise nach Kiev in
schwierigen Zeiten sie kommt aus einer
Union in der sich zunehmend
Kriegsmüdigkeit stellt wo der Fokus nun
auf Israel liegt sie reist in ein Land
in dem ersehnte militärische Erfolge
ausbleiben ein Land das mehr Waffen
braucht als es bekommt und das so sehr
auf Europa
hofft es sind schwere
Entscheidungen manche harte Entscheidung
auch für die Ukraine zu fällen und da
die richtigen Worte zu finden einerseits
der Ermutigung aber andererseits auch
ihnen deutlich zu sagen wir wollen euch
in der Europäischen Union haben aber
dafür muss das Land sich
weiterentwickeln und ihr müsst diese
Reform machen im Flugzeug nach Polen im
Nachtzug in die Ukraine herzlicher
Empfang in kiefev so gut das Verhältnis
zwischen vonlein und Präsident selenski
auch ist beide wissen um die wachsenden
Zweifel in einigen EUStaaten ob die
Ukraine die Kriterien für den Beginn von
beitrittsgesprächen so bald erfüllen
kann die Ukraine macht weiter mit der
Transformation ihrer
Institutionen die reformenerden
fortgesetzt insbesondere werden wir neue
Gesetze verabschieden die den Kampf
gegen Korruption effektiver werden
lassen ob diese Reformen für den Beginn
von beitrittsgesprächen ausreichen wird
von derlin nächsten Mittwoch bewerten
und bekannt geben ihre Reise nach Kiev
verstärkt die Hoffnungen in der
Ukraine und Ulf rollller begleitet für
uns die Reise der
eu-kmissionspräsidentin Ulf wie ist das
einzuschätzen wird Ursula von derlin
beitrittsverhandlung mit der Ukraine
empfehlen ich glaube schon diese ganze
Reise von ursola vonderlin in die
Ukraine steht eigentlich unter der
Überschrift Mut und Hoffnung zu machen
vor allem der Ukraine eben weil die eine
ganz schwierige Zeit hat die Kämpfe der
Ostukraine sind sehr sehr hart mit hohen
Verlusten auf beiden Seiten man kriegt
das nicht so mit weil der Nahostkonflikt
eben die Aufmerksamkeit der Welt abzieht
und das ist eben auch die große SGE der
Ukraine und deshalb braucht dieses Land
eine Hoffnung und das wären eben der
Beginn dieser Gespräche zum Beitritt
Frau vonlein hat noch mal sehr klar in
der Pressekonferenz gemacht dass die
Ukraine gerade beim Thema
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und bei der
Bekämpfung der Korruption große große
Fortschritte gemacht hat deshalb glaube
ich ziemlich sicher dass es diese
Empfehlung gibt aus kieev ulfröer danke
schön und das Gespräch haben wir aus
Termingründen vorher aufgezeichnet
im Krieg zwischen Israel und der Hamas
versucht US Außenminister blinken weiter
zu vermitteln in Jordanien hat er sich
mit arabischen Amtskollegen getroffen
Israels Vormarsch um Gazastreifen geht
unterdessen weiter Israels Armee
kündigte am Morgen an dort die
wichtigste Verkehrsachse vorübergehend
freizugeben damit mehr Menschen vom
umkämpften Norden in den Süden fliehen
können dorthin gelangt sind seit Beginn
der Kämpfe nach US-Angaben bereits 800
000 bis eine Mens bis zu 400000
Palästinenser blieben dagegen im Norden
Tim Kröger
berichtet der Terrorangriff der Hamas
ist heute genau vier Wochen her der
Bodenkrieg im Gazastreifen ist in vollem
Gang nach wie vor ist das Ziel der
israelischen Streitkräfte nach eigenen
Angaben die Vernichtung der Hamas es
werde ein langer Kampf so der
israelische
Verteidigungsminister wir haben
gazastadt vollständig eingekreist Norden
und Süden und haben die wohebiete
erreicht unsere Soldaten kämpfen gegen
Terroristen in den Kommandozentralen und
jene die aus den Tunneln
kommen auch heute sollen wieder mehrere
Ziele im Gazastreifen angegriffen worden
sein dabei seinen mehrere Menschen ums
Leben gekommen so die örtlichen Behörden
ein dreistündiger fluchtkorridor in
Richtung südgasa konnte laut israelisem
Militär wegen Beschusses der Hamas nicht
genut
werden gestern hatten die israelischen
Streitkräfte bestätigt einen
Krankenwagen vor der schieferklinik in
Gaza angegriffen zu haben in dem
Fahrzeug sein hamaskämpfer transportiert
worden in Israel haben heute viele
Angehörige und Unterstützer an die
Geiseln erinnert die während des
terrorangriffs der Hamas vor genau vier
Wochen nach Gaza verschleppt
wurden es ist schon fast ein Monat wir
können nicht schlafen wir können nichts
essen wir können nichts machen so kann
man nicht leben es ist die
Hölle die Regierung müsse alles
unternehmen damit die mehr als 240
Geiseln so schnell wie möglich
freikommen wegen des Krieges im Nahen
Osten sind in Deutschland heute wieder
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen in
Düsseldorf stellte die Polizei bei einer
proalästinensischen Demonstration mit 17
000 Menschen mehrere Plakate sicher auf
den der Holocaust relativiert wurde in
Berlin protestierten laut Polizei und 00
Menschen Stefanie gargosch und Nils
Schneider die Demonstranten verlangen
immer wieder eine Waffenruhe im
Gazastreifen werfen Israel einen
Völkermord vor und rufen Freiheit für
Palästina mehrere tausend Menschen
ziehen am Nachmittag mit ihren
Forderungen durch Berlins Mitte
sofortigen Waffenstillstand eine
sofortige Stopp der Zerstörung des
Massenmordes der Bevölkerung der
Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza weiß zu wenig
um um die Hintergründe und von DAH den
Frieden kann alle Fälle nur gut sein die
Schlussfolgerungen die in Deutschland
gezogen werden aus dem Holocaust sind
nicht bedingungslose Unterstützung für
Israel die Polizei begleitet die
Veranstaltung mit 1000 Einsatzkräften
das zeigt wie hoch sie das
Konfliktpotenzial einschätzt im Vorfeld
hatte sie viele Auflagen
erteilt keine gewealtverherrlichung kein
Aufruf zu Gewaltstraftaten bestimmte
Symboliken bestimmte Ausrufe sind
verboten und auch das Zeigen von
Symbolen verschiedener
Organisation nicht alle halten sich
daran die Polizei sammelt immer wieder
Plakate ein die antisemitisch sind oder
etwa den Holocaust verhamlosen ganz
verschiedene Organisationen hatten
bundesweit zur Demo aufgerufen
demokratieforscher sehen einen
Zusammenschluss von Linken teils
radikalen Gruppen bis hin zu Islamisten
Menschen die sonst eher nicht zusammen
demonstrieren würden dass das dadurch
kommt dass man ideologisch sich eben auf
bestimmte gemeinsame Denkmuster einigen
kann letztlich aus unserer Sicht ist es
dann oft der Antisemitismus der die
Menschen vereint nach Polizeiangaben
wurden mehr als 30 Personen wegen
Verstoßes gegen die Auflagen
festgenommen größere Ausschreitungen
sind
ausgeblieben für die Linkspartei läuft
derzeit nicht so gut die Wahl und
Umfrageergebnisse sind schlecht also
einiges zu besprechen jetzt auf dem
Landesparteitag in Sachsen bei dem
Treffen abwesend zugleich aber
allgegenwärtig ist die trünige Sarah
Wagenknecht denn ihre noch zu gründende
neue Partei könnte der Linken weitere
Stimmen abjagen etwa bei der Europawahl
im kommenden Juni vor allem aber bei den
Landtagswahlen im nächsten Herbst in
Brandenburg Thüringen und eben auch in
Sachsen Anja Schalle aus
Kemnitz die sächsische linke
demonstriert Geschlossenheit auf dem
Parteitag in Kemnitz kein Mandatsträger
aus Sachsen ist zum Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht übergelaufen ihr Name
übrigens fät hier heute nicht dimar Bart
cheaf der Bundestagsfraktion sagt die
Abspaltung sei eine zesur für die Partei
das Ende aber nicht ich will gemeinsam
mit euch an der Zukunft der Linken
arbeiten das wird entscheidend sein und
da werden die Landtagswahlen im nächsten
Jahr für uns eine Weichenstellung sein
denn dort wird entschieden ob die Linke
eine relevante Kraft in diesem Land sein
wird der Osten ist die Herzkammer der
Linken wir haben den Osten etwas
vernachlässigt in der Vergangenheit und
dieseneh haben wir erkannt in Sachsen
verzeichnet die Linke nach der Gründung
des Bündnis Wagenknecht das hier nur als
dieformation bezeichnet wird 30 Partei
Neueintritte und 20 Austritte ich merke
aber dass ich die Stimmung innerhalb der
Partei verändert hat es gibt halt so
eine Entspannung gerade sage ich mal wir
müssen Themen die die Leute beschäftigen
setzen die Leute stellen Fragen wie
sieht es mit der Energiekrise aus kann
ich morgen mein Licht noch anschalten
was kostet mich das ganze diese Krise
könnte für die Linke auch wenn es schwer
werden dürfte aber auch eine Chance sein
die Partei befindet sich im freien Fall
ein Singflug gleichermaßen auch ein
Schrumpfkurs auf dem sie sich bewegt
aber sie wird nicht überrascht von dem
Schritt insofern kann sie sich
strategisch auch neu aufstellen nicht
nur für die Linke in Sachsen geht es am
1 September nächstes Jahr um viel auch
für Bodo ramelo in Thüringen den bislang
einzigen Ministerpräsidenten der Partei
wird diese Wahl eine
schicksalsentscheidung außministerin
berburg ist im Südkaukasus unterwegs sie
will im Konflikt zwischen Aserbaidschan
und Armenien
vermitteln seit Jahrzehnten streiten die
beiden Länder um die Region
Bergkarabach völkerrechtlich gehört sie
zu Aserbaidschan wurde aber mehrheitlich
von armenischen Menschen bewohnt bis der
Konflikt im September eskaliert mit
einer Militäroffensive erobert
Aserbaidschan Bergkarabach mehr als
100.000 armenierinnen und Armenier
mussten fliehen über berbox
Vermittlungsversuch Patrizia
Wiedemeier zwei Tage zwei verfeindete
Länder es ist kein einfacher Besuch
heute am frühen Morgen ist
Außenministerin berärburg unterwegs mit
der peacekeeping Mission der EU in
Armenien an der Grenze zu Aserbaidschan
immer wieder gibt es Angriffe aus
Aserbaidschan im September wurden drei
armenische Soldaten getötet eine
Stahlfabrik
beschossen es gab besonders im Sommer
viele Angriffe um den Fabrikbau zu
verhindern auch dabei wurden zwei
Menschen
verletzt nächste Station eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft nah der
armenischen Hauptstadt Erian hier kamen
200 Armenier aus Bergkarabach unter
werbock verspricht eine Aufstockung der
humanitären Hilfe um 9,3 Millionen Euro
denn Hoffnung auf eine Rückkehr in die
Heimat hat hier kaum einer am Mittag
dann Weiterreise nach Baku in die
Hauptstadt Aserbaidschans beim Gespräch
mit dem Präsidenten und dem
Außenminister ging es um die
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
natürlich um kabach Aserbeidschan
verteidigt sein Vorgehen bbock fordert
friedensverhandlung mit der EU als
Vermittler am 19 und 20 September haben
die militärischen Köpfe unseres Landes
eine antiterroroperation durchgeführt
dre Jahre lang haben wir versucht die
Frage im Dialog zu lösen
vergeblich in der gesamten Region hoffen
die Menschen auf Frieden dafür braucht
es die Bereitschaft zum Wohle aller
Aserbaidschaner und Armenia um ein neues
Miteinander zu ringen man werde
Krisengebiete wie diese hier nicht
vergessen so die Botschaft der
Außenministerin wärburg will vermitteln
sie will Aserbaidschan und Armenien
zurück an den Verhandlungstisch bringen
ein Friedensabkommen ist das Ziel keine
leichte Aufgabe denn die Nachbarstaaten
Russland Iran und Türkei wuhen hier
wehement um mehr
Einfluss ein schweres Erdbeben hat zwei
Provinzen im Nordwesten Nepals
erschüttert mindestens 157 Menschen
kamen ums Leben und es wird befürchtet
dass die Zahl der Todesopfer steigt
hunderte wurden verletzt viele Menschen
wurden in ihren Häusern im Schlaf von
dem Erdbeben überrascht luten leinhaus
berichtet alle Zufahrtswege sind
versperrt zu Fuß müssen Sie die
Verletzten in die einfache ortsklinik
tragen vorbei an dem was von ihren
Häusern geblieben ist die Provinz jacott
traf es besonders schlimm hier war das
Epizentrum die Stöße kamen um
Mitternacht
ich wollte weglaufen als das Haus
zusammenstürzte und ich unter den
Trümmern begraben wurde ich schrie um
Hilfe aber meine Nachbarn waren
ebenfalls in Not und riefen um Hilfe
eine halbe Stunde später hat mich ein
Rettungsteam
gefunden auch in der Nachbarprovinz
rukum bebte die Erde und sie beklagen
viele Tote und Verletzte die wenigen
Hospitäler sind hoffnungslos überfüllt
viele Patienten müssen auf dem Rasen
liegen um drinnen Platz für die
schwerstverletz zu schaffen nur wenige
können mit Flugzeugen in die
Krankenhäuser größerer Städte gebracht
werden Armee und Rettungsteams versuchen
noch in abgeschnittene unglücksgebiete
vorzudringen die Zahl der Toten könnte
noch
steigen ztausende Studierenden in
Deutschland finanzieren ihr Studio mit
einem Kredit der staatlichen Förderbank
KfW und die hat den Zins für die Kredite
auf 9% erhöht das Studierenden Werk
nennt das ein sozialpolitischen Skandal
die SPD Bundestagsfraktion fordert die
Erhöhung zurückzunehmen und alternative
Lösungen zu
prüfen der Schriftsteller Lutz Seiler
ist mit dem renommierten Georg Büchner
Preis geehrt worden bei einem Festakt in
Darmstadt nahm der Romancier und Dichter
die Auszeichnung entgegen seine
literarische Stimme sei unverwechselbar
melancholisch und aufrichtig so hatte
die Jury ihre Wahl begründet ein
wichtiges Thema seilas etwa in seinen
Roman cruso und Stern 111 ist der
Untergang der
DDR Martina vus Tecklenburg die Fußball
buundestrainerin muss gehen und das
hatte sich ja schon so seit einiger Zeit
angedeutet Rudi ne jetzt steht es also
fest wie erwartet hat sich der Deutsche
Fußballbund von Martina FOS Tecklenburg
getrennt nach einem Treffen wurde der
Vertrag jetzt aufgelöst das Nationalteam
wird bereits in der Olympia
Qualifikation von Interimstrainer Horst
rubesch betreut eine der letzten
Amtshandlungen in der Öffentlichkeit für
ihre Spielerinnen nach dem erstrunden
Aus bei der WM nach dem Turnier meldet
sich Martina FOS tcklenburg krank eine
monatelange Hängepartie wird nun vom DFB
und seinem Präsidenten Bernt Neuendorf
beendet nach eingehender Analyse des
enttäuschenden Abschneidens bei der
letzten Weltmeisterschaft bestand ein
vernehmen dass das Team einen
personellen Neuanfang in der sportlichen
Führung benötigt Horst rubesch ist damit
nicht gemeint der Ex-Trainer wird
zurückgeholt denn die
Olympiaqualifikation ist in höchster
Gefahr Feuerwehrmann rubes startet mit
zwei Siegen gegen Wales und auf Island
eine Option für die Zeit nach Olympia
ist der aber nicht die Nachfolge bleibt
offen gerade erst im Frühjahr war ihr
Vertrag bis 2025 verlängert worden das
WM fiasco ändert alles nun geht Martina
FOS Tecklenburg
vorzeitig die Fußballerinnen des SC
Freiburg haben der TSG Hoffenheim
überraschend die erste Saisonniederlage
zugefügt die breeisgauerin gewannen in
sinshheim mit 3:2 durch die Niederlage
am sechsten Spieltag verpassten die
hoffenheimerinnen die zwischenzeitliche
Übernahme der
Tabellenführung die ersten
samstagsergebnisse der männerbundesliga
auch am 10N Spieltag ist Bayer
Leverkusen die Mannschaft der Stunde das
3:2 in Hoffenheim war der zehnte
Pflichtspielsieg in Folge bei Union
Berlin verschlimmert sich die Krise 0:3
gegen Eintracht Frankfurt köln- Augsburg
1:1 Mainz 05 mit dem ersten Saisonsieg z
:0 gegen Leipzig SC Freiburg
Mönchengladbach 3:3 Freitag spielten
Darmstadt 98 VfL Bochum 12 und das
Topspiel Borussia Dortmund Bayern
München ausführlich im Aktuellen
Sportstudio ab 23 Uhr in der Tabelle
baut Leverkusen den Vorsprung vor Bayern
München vorübergehend auf fünf Punkte
aus Stuttgart und Dortmund spielen noch
heute bzw morgen keine Veränderungen in
der oberen
Tabellenhälfte die untere Hälfte beginnt
mit Augsburg der el Bochum verbessert
sich um drei Plätze auf 13 Mainz jetzt
Vorletzter vorschlusslicht erster fC
Köln Deutschlands Handballer sind mit
einem Unentschieden in die Vorbereitung
der Heim em gestartet gegen
Afrikameister Ägypten gelang in neuulm
ein 31 z31 beste Werfer der
Nationalmannschaft mit G5 Treffern Juri
Knorr und Timo kastening der hier einen
schnellen Gegenstoß erfolgreich
abschließt bei seinem länderspieldebü
glänzte David spet im Tor mit Spek
kulieren Paraden Trainer Alfred
gisslerson sah bei seinem Team Höhen und
Tiefen wie er sagte vielleicht klappt's
dann morgen mit dem Sieg gegen Ägypten
in München beim nächsten Test ab 17:15
Uhr live hier im ZF Jana sehr schön
danke Rudi bitte König schalz der dritte
ein frisch gebackener Monarch stimmt
nicht ganz in diesem Fall doch es geht
um den King als Kuchen Körper und Krone
bedeckt mit Zuckerpaste und reiscispies
Charles Gesicht Schokoladenguss ein
Licker an dem eine britische Künstlerin
eine Woche lang gearbeitet hat und nun
kommt das Backwerk in den
buckinghamalast darf der König Kosten
noch
unklar im Süden stürmisch sonst regnet
es immer wieder mehr zum Herbstwetter
gleich von Christer Orben das heute
journal können Sie an diesem Abend um
22:45 Uhr sehen mit Christian siebas
[Musik]
tschüss
guten Abend das bunte Herbstlaub fällt
jetzt mehr und mehr die Sturmtiefs
sorgen dafür tiefer Luftdruck herrscht
morgen über ganz Europa wir haben orange
eingefärbt die Sturm und orkanfelder die
schon wieder die Biskaya und den
Mittelmeerraum treffen auch bei uns wird
es morgen im Süden stürmisch wir schauen
zunächst auf die Nacht da die
Regenwolken nach Nordosten ab aus
Südwesten folgen aber die nächsten
kräftigen Schauer mit kurzen Gewittern
die Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2°
damit bleibt es frostfrei morgen liegen
die Höchstwerte zwischen 9° in Bergland
und 14° in der Lausitz und dazu ist es
ein grauer Tag am ersten lockert es im
Osten auf hier auch anfangs noch trocken
sonst ziehen morgen aber immer wieder
Regengebiete aus Südwest über uns hinweg
ganz im Südwesten kann es auch mal für
ein kurzes Gewitter reichen ein
wichtiges Thema der Wind nicht im Norden
Wirt er schwach im Süden aber denn da
ist es stürmisch in den Hochlagen
südlich des Mainz sind Orkanböhen
möglich vorsicht vor umstürzenden Bäumen
und ebenfalls windig und unbeständig
folgt die nächste Woche bis zum Mittwoch
wird es noch etwas kühler ja so stellt
man sich den Herbst vor tschüss